bonsoir merci d'être avec nous le
kremlin qui a donc attendu les résultats
officiels vladimir poutine est l'un des
rares pour ne pas dire le seul peut-être
dirigeants avoir attendu jusque-là
faut-il y voir un message tacite envoyé
à joe biden c'est un message évidemment
mais c'est un message obligatoire il est
très clair que à partir du moment où les
grands électeurs ont voté que le
président élu est définitivement joe
biden la dmr poutine devait le prendre
acte et envoyé son message de
félicitations qu'il avait d'ailleurs
promis pour le candidat qui serait
désigné par les dents et lecteurs
au début du mois de novembre donc il n'y
a pas là réellement de surprises ce qui
est très intéressant dans le télégramme
que vladimir poutine a envoyé c'est la
volonté de collaborer mais attention
collaborer sur des principes d'égalité
de respect mutuel et ça ce n'est pas
forcément sûr que ce soit la vision que
les etats-unis ont de la russie
effectivement joe biden avait dit alors
donné mille cent soixante cinq minutes
sur nbc que
la russie était le pays le plus menaçant
quelque sorte pour les états unis avant
la chine même est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre tout de même qu'il y ait une
réponse à cette main tendue de la part
de vladimir poutine
il y aura forcément une réponse est
vraisemblablement la réponse ne sera pas
totalement négative c'est à dire qu' il
est de l'intérêt de joe biden de laisser
les portes ouvertes
parce que la situation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ne peut pas continuer très
longtemps
on est dans une situation très complexe
au niveau mondial
la russie n'est plus la puissance
d'antan mais c'est une puissance très
importante notamment par sa puissance
nucléaire et les états unis ont tout
intérêt à traiter avec comme disait le
président richard nixon dans un de ses
livres
ils ont intérêt à traiter avec la seule
puissance dans le monde capables de les
détruire
actuellement le grand adversaire c'est
la chine mais elle n'a pas encore la
chine la capacité de détruire les états
unis la russie avec son arsenal
nucléaire
le possède donc il y a là un enjeu vital
il est évident qu'une guerre nucléaire
aujourd'hui entre la russie et les etats
unis est impensable
il n'y a pas d'enjeu suffisant pour cela
en revanche il est toujours intéressant
pour les interlocuteurs de garder des
démesures de négociation des termes de
négociations et là il ya un enjeu majeur
qui se dessine c'est que le traité d'
équilibre nucléaire que l'on appelle new
stats vient qui a été signé en 2010
vient à son terme en février 2021
or pour le moment rien n'a été négocié
pour sa suite qu'est ce qui va se passer
ensuite
est ce que les traités start vont
s'arrêter là
c'est peu recommandables pour l'
équilibre mondial
est ce que on va prendre au projet le
traité pendant un temps de négociations
supplémentaires
de toute façon il est très clair qu'il
n'est de l'intérêt de personne
aujourd'hui de s'engager dans une
nouvelle course à l'armement
d'autant plus qu'il ya des arts nouvelle
qui change complètement les équilibres
donc les négociations sont presque
obligatoire est ce qu'elles vont avoir
lieu
ça dépend des états unis puisque la
russie a déjà depuis longtemps déclaré
qu'elle était prête à négocier
en tout cas joe biden de son côté avait
promis avant d'être élu de se montrer
fermes face à la russie accusé on le
rappelle a notamment d' ingérence
présumée dans le système électoral
américain on peut s'attendre à un statu
quo pas de changements notamment dans la
poursuite des sanctions à l'encontre de
la russie
les sanctions à mon avis ne vont pas
changer du moins pas tout de suite il
faudra plusieurs mois voire peut-être
même des années avant que les choses
évoluent en tout cas ce qui est très
clair c'est que les démocrates ont fait
beaucoup de battage en 2016 pour
contester l'élection de donald trump
autour de l'ingérence russe les enquêtes
sur l'ingérence russe à l'intérieur du
système américain n'ont rien donné elles
se sont toutes conclues par l'absence
totale de d'éléments pouvant prouver une
intervention digne de ce nom de la part
de la russie
les liens entre donald trump et la
russie sont tombées à l'eau il n'y a
rien
mais les démocrates ne peuvent pas se
déjuger aujourd'hui sont bien obligés de
dire mais oui il y a
eu interférence il ya eu ingérence russe
donc il continue sur cette voie là
jusqu'au moment où ils diront lorsque
tout cela sera oublié
ils diront oui eh bien on va repartir
d'un nouveau pied on va faire quelque
chose de différent mais de toute manière
la diabolisation de la russie continuera
parce que je crois que c'est dans les
gènes actuelle du système politique
américain
il faut qu'il y ait un ennemi un ennemi
pour non pas pour les etats-unis mais
pour le temps si les américains veulent
conserver l'otan il faut que la russie
soit l'ennemi alors il y a évidemment ce
que vous venez nous expliquer la
géopolitique les enterrer évidemment
supérieur des nations mais il ya aussi
les relations entre les hommes qui
peuvent parfois arranger bien des choses
comment vous voyez la relation entre
l'homme
joe biden est l'âme mais demir poutine
si j'ose dire
c'est très difficile c'est une question
qui est très difficile à répondre
simplement parce que les relations entre
joe banner et lorsqu'il était
vice-président et vladimir poutine
étaient très correctes byden est une
personnalité est un véritable homme
politique américain il est copain avec
tout le monde
il serre la main tout le monde il sourit
il rit avec tout le monde mais ça c'est
la façade derrière il ya d'autres choses
mais en tout cas les relations étaient
cordiales en revanche il ya un élément
qui est très important dans les
relations aujourd'hui entre vladimir
poutine et joe biden
c'est la faire un tabac iden son fils
qui est compromis dans une affaire de
corruption en ukraine
c'est la fameuse affaire but risma et
les clés de cette affaire sont
évidemment à kiev
mais les américains font le nécessaire
pour étouffer tout ce qui est possible
en revanche il y a beaucoup d'éléments à
moscou et ces éléments de moscou peuvent
surgir à n'importe quel moment et c'est
ça le véritable
jeu qui peut se nouer entre baden et et
poutine est ce que réellement poutine
peut influencer d'une manière bien
entendu en sous main pour que la sphère
byden éclater au grand jour la faire un
tabac y donne évidemment
ou bien est ce qu'au contraire il va
rester tranquille il va se tait il ne va
rien faire de manière à ne pas
compromettre les futures relations avec
les états unis
c'est vraisemblable c'est
vraisemblablement la deuxième solution
qui sera adoptée mais cela place alors
que vladimir poutine n'avait aucun
aucune influence réelle sur donald trump
il peut avoir une influence dans la
grâce à cela sur dubaï
merci beaucoup aux pierre laurent
journaliste écrivain nous avoir apporté
votre éclairage